elle de londres catherine chaque tam
spécialiste du moyen-orient c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur
bonsoir catherine chaque dame merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france alors pas
de crimes de guerre mais des incidents
isolés c'est l'argument relevé par
londres pour légitimer sa décision
pourtant l'année dernière le
gouvernement britannique avait lui même
admis que les armes fabriquées au
royaume uni avait joué un rôle central
dans le bombardement du yémen comment
comprendre ce retournement économique
naissante et y est je n'aime pas ce que
c'est la nécessité économique
le renommer me gênait pas refusé de
l'argent aujourd'hui et la vente des
armes
l'arabie saoudite est il très à
pratiquer le droit a toujours suivi ce
principe
l'arabie saoudite est un allié très
tactique est intéressant dans la région
le royaume uni est donc prêt à détourner
le regard face aux crimes commis au yen
elle est la logique sous jacente est un
peu biaisé souvent le gouvernement
adopte la position suivante comme le
gouvernement du yémen est considéré
comme un gouvernement illégitime alors
tout ce qui pourrait arriver à ce
gouvernement ou aux individus qui lui
mais ils sont liés mais n'a pas
l'importance de leur point de vue ils
considèrent soutenir le pouvoir légitime
au yémen et il se considère donc pas
comme opérant en dehors du droit
international c'est une vitre est brisée
laissé seul hic adopte le gouvernement
britannique
et c'est pour cela que cela peut
coïncider avec des politiques contre les
violations des droits humanitaires donc
le croyais ennemi peut continuer à dire
qu'il défend le droit et medicare et les
trois incarnations
les cela concerne en premier lieu les
intérêts financiers du royaume uni et là
que très peu à voir avec la recherche
d'une solution au conflit au yémen où
les morts au yémen où le moyen de
rationaliser des morts civiles au yémen
tout cela est écartée parce que cela ne
correspond pas au discours général et
ceux que l'on voit aujourd'hui c'est un
exemple tout à fait classique qui est de
posture politique adoptée par le royaume
uni alors cette annonce intervient il
faut le préciser au lendemain d'une
vague de sanction inédite imposée par le
royaume uni à 20 saoudien pour vol et
violation aux droits humains soupçonné
d'avoir joué un rôle dans le meurtre en
2018 du journaliste
khashoggi un jamal khashoggi à istanbul
selon vous est ce qu'il ya un lien ce
qui vaut au le voir d'un côté le royaume
uni déclare qu'il a agi contre ces
violations des droits de l'homme parce
que effectivement 7 à 6 me à aller était
un crime flagrant ne pouvait pas être
défendue donc le royaume uni devait agir
ce n'est pas forcément ce qu'il fallait
faire car nous ne savons pas encore à ce
jour si les personnes accusées été
véritablement coupable on ne sait pas en
tout cas si ce sont bien eux qui ont
pris la décision
on ne sait pas où les décisions ont été
prises en arabie saoudite
s'agissant du yémen il s'agit d'une
décision du gouvernement de perpétrer
des crimes contre l'humanité au yémen le
royaume uni est prêt à agir contre des
individus n'est pas contre un
gouvernement
qui pour le royaume uni est un allié et
non seulement régaliennes également un
partenaire très utile puis notamment en
matière de politique étrangère
donc c'est une posture très pratique
pour le royaume uni
ils agissent parfois mais pas
systématiquement
parce que politiquement ils doivent
ménager l'arabie saoudite
ils doivent continuer à défendre leurs
intérêts qui sont liées aux couleurs
pour le royaume-uni l'arabie saoudite
agit dans la lignée de leurs intérêts
propres
donc ils pourront continuer ses actions
ils seront ils bénéficieront de toute
fin à l'impunité du monde
ma dernière question l'onu décrit le
conflit au yémen comme la pire crise
humanitaire au monde
quelle réaction du côté justement des
nations unies et des associations
humanitaires face à cette décision
britannique connaît mieux qu'un point en
intime d'une question difficile
certaines personnes vont s'exprimer vous
prendre la parole contre la réunion et
en critiquant justement à l'hypocrisie
de leurs positions mais il ne s'agit là
que de mots et jusqu'à ce que des
actions surprises sur le terrain il est
très facile de dire ce qu'il faut faire
ou faudrait faire au yémen la guerre
doit cesser on doit apporter une aide et
au civil il doit apporter de la
nourriture et une aide humanitaire en
général ou yémen mais est-ce que cela va
arriver ça n'est pas sûr car lorsqu'on
parle d' aide humanitaire la question
est tout de suite comment s'assurer que
cette aide arrive bien aux bonnes
personnes et n'arrive pas plutôt à des
extrémistes
c'est un problème que tous les partis
doivent étudier et résoudre au yémen il
est difficile de justifier l'action et
du royaume uni
les autres pays seront tout à fait prêt
à détourner le regard si cela correspond
également à la rhétorique qu'ils
produisent et autres pays serait
également tout à fait prêt sans doute à
faire commerce avec l'arabie saoudite
la différence c'est qu'on n'en parle pas
dans les journaux
merci catherine chaque code chaque dame
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france